(pleurs de bébé)
- Ils arrivent ici
aux poe e e e la mort.
L'unité de malnutrition
de l2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2s
petits et les plus émaciés
eseseses patients. Mais le nombe
d'admissions explose. d d d d dt
le chef des soins pédiatriques.
En fait, dans plusieurs
des lits, ce sont souvent
trois patients qui oscillent
entre les pleurs et
la difficulté à respirer.
(pleurs de bébé)
Les jumeaux Hazeat Musa
et Hazrat Esaa bataillent
pour survivre depuis
trois semaines ici.
"Nous n'avons rien à manger
à la maison, dit-elle,
nous sommes pauvres. Mon mari
ne sort plus travailler."
Zarghona, leur mère, dit
qu'elle a perdu neuf enfants
dans le passé.
De quoi sont-ils morts?
Elle n'en est pas certaine.
Ce qu'elle sait, c'est que
les quatre enfants toujours
en vie qu'elle a laissés
derrière pour venir
depuis son village
ne vont pas beaucoup mieux.
"Les enfants sont malades,
dit Zarghona, mais on n'a pas
les moyens de les soigner."
L'Unicef parle d'une urgence
silencieuse. Les problèmes
de malnutrition ne sont
pas nouveaux en Afghan
mais les derniers chiffres
sont alarmants, dit l'organisme.
Entre 'a'a'a'a'a'août
et décembre 2021,
le nombre d'enfants admis
pour malnutrition dans
les hôpitaux afghans a doublé,
passant de 2407 à 4214.
Le taux dentntntntntntnt,
cet état de malnutrition aiguë
qui réduit ses poupons
à la peau et aux os,
s'élève à près de 10 %.
La pauvreté est une des grandes
responsables. On estime que
97 % des Afghans vivent
sous le seuil de la pauvreté.
Mais selon le directeur
des soins pédiatriques ici,
l'ignorance est un facteur
aggravant pernicieux.
On peut difficilement croire
que la petite Sayera a
quatre ans. C'est
ce qu'indique son dossier
médical. C'est sa grand-mère qui
l'a amenée pour être soignée.
"À la maison, sa mère s
d'un autre enfant. Elle n'a que
12 ans", nous dit la grand-mère.
(appel du muezzin)
Et comme si la crise n'était
pas assez sévère, l'Afghanistan,
en ce moment, fait face à
une sécheresse d
qu'elle n'a pas connue depuis
près de trois décennies.
Zergaï craint de perdre 70 %
de ses revenus cette année,
alors qu'au marché, le prix
augmente pour tout. La farine,
l'huile, et l'essence dont
il a besoin pour fai
fonctionner la pompe qui lui
permet d'irriguer ses champs,
déjà, dit-il, il s'est endetté
pour payer le salaire de
son employé.
Nematullah cr
des conséquences à beaucoup
plus long terme. La terre
familiale et tout le travail
de ses ancêtres avant lui
pourraient être anéantis.
"Il faut 100 ans de dur travail,
dit-il, pour avoir un jardin
qui donne de bons fruits.
Mes ancêtres ont travaillé très
fort pour planter ses arbres et
prendre soin de cette terre."
Ces canaux d'irrigation sont
complètement à sec depuis
des mois. Il lui reste un peu
mo, , , , , , , , , , , dit-il,
pour sauver ces arbres qui
commencent à dessécher.
"Il faut 10 jours pour que l'eau
du barrage arrive ici quandt,t,i
le barrage n'a pas assez d'eau,
nous aurons beaucoup de
problèmes. Nous n'avons pas
les moyens de creuser desititits
de dépérir."
Quelque 20 000 hectares
dans la province de Kandahar
dépendent du barrage de Dahla
pour être irrigués. Mais
ce barrage construit dans
les années 1950 se fait vieux.
En 2008, le Canada a débloqué
50 millions $ pour moderniser
le canal principal du barrage
et 60 canaux secondaires.
Le projet, controversé àvavavave
une vitrine de la présence
du Canada à Kandahar.
A
des efforts mitigés, il
n'est plus que le souvenir
d'une promesse non tenue pour
les agriculteurs ici.
Les fruits menacent de tomber
avant même la maturi
Nematullah, qui dit tout voir
en noir.
"Nous avons peur de perdre
notre jardin, dit-il,
mais nous n'avons pas peur
de manquer de nourriture.
Allah a promis de donner
à manger à l'humanité."
(cris d'enfants)
Il semble, pourtant,
tout aussi impuissant que
ces mères désemparées, à calmer
les cris de douleur incessants
des plus vulnérables parmi
les Afghans.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Kandahar